- Lisa Banfield a témoignéeseses
devant la commission des pertes
massives et devant environ
150 personnes, dont plusieurs
familles de victimes.s s s s s ,
la voix tremblante, elle est
revenue sur les violences
qu'elle a subies au cours
des 19 ans de vie e e e e e e e.
L'avocate de la commission lui
a demandé pourquoi elle n'a pas
signalé à la police qu'il avait
obtenu illégalement des armes à
Elle a répondu qu'elle avait
peur.
Elle a raconté un épisode où
il l'a menacée avec un pistolet.
Elle étadededededededededededed.
Quand la police a frappé
à la porte de leur appartement
de Dartmouth en 2010 après
une plainte pour menace  e e e n
conjoint n'avait pas d'armes à
feu chez lui, car elle craignait
qu'il se mette à tirer depuis
leur chambre àlelelelelelelelel.
L'avocate lui a aussi demandé
si elle soupçonnait que
Gabriel Wortman était capable de
commettre des 18 et 19 avril 20.
Lisa Banfield a répondu
qu'il racontait souvent des
bêtises, y compris qu'il voulait
mourir de façon spectaculaire,
attention et quittait la pièce.
Lisa Banfielde e souvient aussi
que le tueur conduisait parfois
un ancien véhicule de la GRC,
réfléchissantes sur les côtés,
mais q é était suffisamment
impressionnant pour que les gens
s'écartent sur son passage.
à ce qu'a dit un autre témoin,
elelle assure qu'elle ne l'a
jamais vu conduire la copie
presque conforme d'une a a a a e
pendant la tuerie d'avril 2020.
sisisisisisisisisisisisisisisisd
ment, si elle dit la vérité
ou si elle se trompe", a dit
l'avocat d'une majorité
des familles de victitititititie
d'aujourd'hui, son équipe évalue
maintenant une autre procédure
judiciaire pour obtenir
des réponses dcicicicicicicicic,
Radio-Canada, Halifax